biggest news ever congratulations this
is amazing I mean this take us from the
beginning
talk about your planning process
planning wise Wow I started on the ring
shopping
late April so it took a while my family
jewelry store my that my uncle runs his
Wentz jewelry up north by the lake and I
started working with them and April
built her like a custom ring that I knew
she would love but I didn't ask her
opinion on anything because I didn't
want to give it away I just paid
attention when she talked about other
people's rings and what she didn't like
I just and then yes last week we just
had this day planned where we were gonna
go hang out I wanted to show her Toronto
Island she's never been to the island
and I always said it's beautiful
different view of the city and all that
stuff so about two months ago I planted
the seed if we need to have a Toronto
day we need to have a Toronto day so
that it wouldn't be so weird that I'm
packing a picnic and we're going on a
random Toronto day and then everything
just worked out the the one day it
didn't rain you had to work it out
because we were having fun yeah she was
leaving for a family trip on the
Thursday and went or Tuesday was a
rainstorm so I had the Wednesday with
like a two-hour window of sunshine to
like make it all work and I convinced
her to go for a picnic and a bike ride
and the one thing that's sealed it for
her
was I had my best friend call me and on
speakerphone I made him say a script
that I texted to him hey buddy so I'm
gonna send you where to go on the island
just meet me there I'm gonna come over
with beers and I made him seem like
we're just having a hangout great so she
had no clue that there was actually like
a romantic aspect that was gonna be nice
so how surprised were you I had no idea
at all and I'm usually very I feel like
self-aware of knowing everything that's
going on it did think he was kind of
being strange cuz he kept he was
blow-drying his hair which he never
really does and he put on a watch I'm
like why are we getting so dressed up to
go drink beer on the island he's like oh
if it's dressed up for me to wear
anything other than vans this looks
really bad fine but um but other than
that I had absolutely no clue if you
zoom in on the photo that we got of me
on one knee you can see in her face like
she I could see the moment where it was
okay why is he's making me stand here I
could see the
moment from that's a holy it's happening
like I can see your face turn and now
I've been hinting that I'm gonna propose
sometime before February it was always
my thing I'm like I'll do it before
you're 30
I'll do it around Christmas and I was
brushing it off I even hinted that I
might do it through the show I might
just to get her completely off track
even though that was never at all there
was a there wasn't something about doing
it at another person's wedding in Mexico
was that supposed to be yeah so Rachel
she was the Bachelorette that's Astrid
one of asteroids best friends and we
went down to their wedding and I brought
it with me just to well she thinks it's
crazy I put it in my checked bag and and
we decided to have one day by ourselves
after everyone left and that day she
just happened to be I just don't want to
be in Mexico at a romantic place and not
have it with me just in case the the
moment was right and then it wasn't so
we got home from that trip on the Monday
and I just waited the day before I did
it so we I'm still like a little shocked
that you put it in checked luggage so
right on the way there and on the way
back and okay I was nervous she'd be
looking for headphones or something and
then just like I don't know you're right
I probably so your family's they must be
so excited you guys just seem like you
fit so well from the moment we first saw
you on the show but then beyond and
we're sure your families feel the same
way oh yeah they're very excited I feel
like they've been waiting for I feel
like they've probably been urging this
more than I ever really pressured them
to do this yeah so I facetimed two weeks
before I did it I facetimed her mom
stepdad and her sister and asked them
all and they all cried all through and
then her mom was be texting me randomly
like so we really just like waiting for
it to happen
and then because the ring I got my mom
helped me with picking it up and stuff
so they all knew everyone was just
really excited I think we're just
excited to start planning a wedding
sure so how long is the planet like some
people like to have long engagements
some people like to have short
engagements what are you thinking for
yours so we're kind of thinking end of
next year maybe like November time
because I want to do in Florida where I
know it's gonna be warm regardless yeah
want to wait till hurricane season is
over we're kind of thinking mid-november
we're gonna pick one before the end of
our yeah no we're gonna have a set day
yeah
so how involved will the Batchelor
franchise be or about sort of paradise
franchise be and will Chris Harrison
you know oversee the wedding what are
you guys thinking well Chris Harrison
will get a invite with Lauren but they
will have no requirements to work at all
they just have to come and have a beer
with me there's no there's no we have
our own idea of how our weddings gonna
go it's going to be a little smaller a
little more intimate and when it comes
to the bachelor side we just have our
friends I feel like it's it's meant for
some people and we don't think there's
anything wrong with it yeah I just think
for us we're I don't know just kind of
grow that part I think yeah I think
we've grown I forget I met her on a show
all the time it's crazy I really forget
that we met on a crazy beach with crazy
people like you so we appreciate the
show and like it's the brought us so
much in the moment and all of that and
like we've enjoyed watching paradise
this season even to like remember like
wow this was less a year ago how crazy
yeah but I don't it's just she's done
yeah we've kind of moved on yeah and I
think we want to bring our friends that
we've met like Joe and Kendall for
example I want them to be at our wedding
because they're our friends that saw us
meet and saw the whole thing start but
we're not going to we're not gonna just
invite all the random big names because
we're on a show yeah yeah I think that's
really the point of that show to
eventually you are supposed to go off
and fly on your own as humans as as a
couple right and you guys have actually
done it which is really nice that's
really cool yeah so speaking about the
bachelor in paradise what do you think
about this new season who's gonna make
it who do you guys have your eye on oh
well you're the I may be actually hasn't
really been watching it too much I've
been watching but um watching him just
like how do we meet on the shower
pretty but no but it's also amped up a
lot since you're thinking so - I see the
series very different just like the
stuff that they're showing and I feel
like our season was a lot more playful
and had a lot more serious people I
guess on it I feel like the two seasons
of The Bachelor Bachelorette leading up
were really young yeah like with Hannah
and I just feel like it was young people
so when you get the like the John Paul
Jones in a speedo every episode like
we've never thought there's gonna be a
proposal with him and Taoiseach is that
you think that's gonna happen
yeah I saw that but knowing him he could
just also be tying his shoe like I feel
like so yeah I met him we met him at
Chris and crystals wedding and I met him
at the urinal and it came up beside me
and he flicked my hair he goes bro
you're my hero that's how we that's how
I met Jay PJ he is he reminds me of that
hockey player from high school like he
is just the bro of all Bros I can't see
him getting engaged I don't know
personally if he is or not but I can't
see him doing it that quick person
anything well you never know
you never know thanks so much guys for
having our best of luck oh thank you
you